you were talking about imagination
earlier you never want to lose the
imagination because once you do that I
feel like you
you're clipped yeah you castrated or
something you lose your imagination yeah
you can't stick it up anymore at that
point is that what castration is I'm
sorry I know a lot of big words but I
don't remember
yeah I like that it's a new album title
yeah here's your name
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dopasio
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast this is my co-host
Marty O'Neal what's up guys what's up
guys today the double usual podcast you
know we're here to talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between and you guys been bugging
since season one I couldn't tell you how
many comments we had to have this man on
the show right here guys it's finally
here this is zombie juice Flatbush
Zombies thank you very much hey hey
thanks for being guys Thomas smarty
let's go I hear that
sometimes names as I shake their hand
sometimes you know I try to uh engage
everyone here so I can lock it in yeah I
try to try to do it it's super hard for
me I can remember a whole movie I can't
remember hey Jim or hey Marcus it's the
worst it's hard it brings me on
autopilot
um we didn't really start
I got a lot of stuff I want to ask you
today but starting before we say oh no
let's talk about the show you said your
name is like kind of just my street name
and now I wanted a cool rap name yeah
yeah I feel like like like juice came
from uh my Yu-Gi-Oh days no way and my
um my um my listening to Nellie Pimp
Juice stays
that was good and I love the movie Juice
and um I need a name while I was
battling in Yu-Gi-Oh I need a cool name
you know Kaiba you know Yugi those are
cool names
yeah you have a great imagination
because I always watch my homies
you're just playing cards man but I
can't imagine him pop up and fight uh
your imagination runs well oh yeah I've
been doing this in my room that's
fighting as a kid we used to play with
the skate decks that's terrible yeah
before you got here I was dude I do this
all the time yeah I think I just have
ADHD or something I'm PR I needed a cool
name I need a school name what would you
have picked if it wasn't that if it
wasn't that like genuinely what would it
have been because you said hard hat Bill
hard hat I mean that's some new [__]
that's my new my new [__] when I gamble
hard hat bill
um
hard candy Randy that's another candy my
friend said I can't use that one because
I didn't know what that meant what is
that bad how's that bad it sounds kind
of suspect hard candy Randy that's what
hard candy was like heroin or something
yeah oh but then they're telling me that
it's like some some nasty stuff so I'm
like oh that's back out so I'm like just
be something else so hard hat Bill works
it's like hard hat build it works
because he's a construction worker wait
I'm not a construction worker but the
identity is like a hard-working man that
is like gambling some of his earnings so
hard hat bill it's a great character so
you're like yeah I didn't lose it build
it Bill lost it it makes you feel
unprotected I love that I gotta start
doing that in life but um yeah I like
the I don't know I like uh Dr Doom a
little bit but the name of doomism of
Dooms that doesn't work
um I couldn't figure it out I still
can't figure it out I like the name
Raven when I was a kid Raven with that
so raven took that out of there yeah
that people associate you with a Disney
yeah mine was a Carne West and I always
do it in Spanish West because I'm
Spanish
or was it biological stepfather
biological yo stop doing music just do
jokes fool because that's all this is
one of my friends I can't say when his
AOL screen names was Ronald McDonald
that's all right that's terrible that
goes with the hard hat uh Hard Candy
Rain yeah but it's like that's 90s
that's 90 stuff when you're just talking
yeah it was back in the day
yeah exactly it was AOL
um yeah so I just wanted to know so hard
hat build not hard candy Randy
definitely so now we're at zombie juice
yeah I think it's awesome yeah it's kind
of a a wild name I saw you retreated uh
we just had DJ I'm in here he redid All
Those epic scenes
together I had the Queen Latifah brought
her out too come on yeah yeah he was
showing us Clips like I was shocked we
even said who's queening
there's only one Queen yeah
drama you know when you ask people
certain things like why can't you oh
forgot man sorry we're just chilling so
that's that's how I feel with it um
before I forget
hope Lord your homie talking Terps oh
you [__] I forgot because I had
a whole Toy to bring you a knife oh it's
all good so I forgot I came here no it's
all good I I met that dude in passing at
a Cannabis Cup in 2016.
real cool didn't see him for two three
years and then I saw back to another
story this first time we met I told
Marty this season one I'll find it on
season one I said I've seen about five
live shows that I was just shocked live
shows live artists playing okay I was
like 19 Tech Nine blew my mind when he
had his show and and the king of
Darkness was coming out and he was
rapping and the smoke was going around
his body as he's on stage see him three
times before I'm already love it right
um
obviously War because I'm in every
California fair as a child CC war and
then you guys played smokers club 2018.
2018 right there by the water that was
cool by the water yeah yeah right right
but you guys came out and I told you
like I've never seen people uh
command an audience bro the whole thing
was everybody on as you guys were saying
go and it just start I couldn't believe
I remember which youthfuls were wearing
you know what I mean like I remember
that I like those Beetlejuice type
stripe pants or some [__] it was why
then you're Grateful Dead the green tie
top car was like I heard of these fools
never seen him live and that's that's
pretty much the myth became a fan man
the myths the legends that wants to be
that was awesome man uh so live shows
crushing it so that's where I was
getting onto three years later that's
where I saw hope was like oh I'm with
fire with them doing some [__] like you
just stopped doing well you know you're
in the music so that's what I wanted to
bring him up because I haven't seen him
yeah me I hope at this brand called
talking Terps yeah talking Terps yeah
dude it's beautiful the toys it's
beautiful hopefully we'll get into some
cannabis we actually got uh some stuff
with Fidel we make like Littles
I smoke weed yet we try to we try to
like ease into that okay we would do
because YouTube's like yo you said a
cuss word
no we're mad like
how would you describe talking Terps
like the whole aesthetic of the brand
looking at the website it's so unique
and cool looking it's a cool uh
Community to collect have friends our
Discord is amazing the communion Discord
is amazing it's a cool place to collect
new art that's not tacky wheat um but
there's more collectible this is more
more bright it is an expression of a
part of me it reminds me of the of the
level that bear breaks are on oh wow you
know what I mean like they're like yo
what is this because all the time they
see that my homie's like these little
bricks and cause dolls like five years
ago and go that's pretty cool let's go
and that's where I saw your guys's stuff
um I just hired a creative designer for
my brand and he knows all you guys I
didn't know that he knows uh he's like
check this brand out talking to her like
why do I know that name because we were
a brainstormed the other days like this
brand is amazing when they're doing like
their toys it's like I want to make
plushies nice we got some like we can't
copy this but look at what they're doing
yeah please do and then I saw it no then
I saw it I saw the picture I'm like is
that a whole floor what the hell is
going on yeah no hair yeah with no hair
that's what threw me off dude he had no
hair but I just remember like oh he's
some dude from like the East Coast
smoking weed he had
it's cool to hear you say that it's like
a bear Brook kind of vibe to me it's
just an expression so to hear what
people think about is cool I see it as
like a
well I just went to New York for the
first time recently and when I went to
some certain stores like shoes fashion
mad sick toys because I got a toy room I
mean we collect towards our whole I'm
pretty sure you guys collected toys
I do you know so it feels good to be
able to put something in that space and
yeah it's great dude I love like it's
like a it's like a whole life it reminds
me kind of like a
wet willy and Flame remember uh from
World Industries how it was just oh it
was fun people made something fun that's
what everybody like you were talking
about imagination earlier you never want
to lose the imagination because once you
do that I feel like you
you're clipped yeah you castrated or
something you lose your imagination yeah
you can't stick it up anymore at that
point it's real is that what castration
is I'm sorry I know a lot of big words
but I don't remember yeah I like that
it's a new album title yeah
that's my new rapper name mental
castration
that's true
[Music]
for a lot of us quitting cold turkey is
extremely hard to do but fume has made
it really easy to break those bad habits
of course we're talking about our
sponsor fume they look at the problem in
a different way instead of drastic
uncomfortable changes why not just
remove the bad from your habit fume is
an Innovative award-nominated device
that does just that instead of
electronics fumes completely natural
instead of Vapor Fumes using flavored
Air instead of harsh harmful chemicals
used in natural delicious ingredients
you guys get it instead of bad fume is
good all right break those bad habits
your fume comes with adjustable airflow
as you can see I've been twisting this
thing as you can hear it movable Parts
it's magnetic it's just here for
fidgeting all right for the stressful
situations when we're all flipping pens
might as well flip around a few it
tastes more flavorful than I thought and
it feels very fresh the real wood and
the shape beautiful I feel cool using
this so if you want a fun way to
gradually stop those bad habits go to
trifum.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use our code at
checkout Dau that's going to get you 10
off the journey pack let's try fum.com
use code Dau for an additional 10 off
your order try fume
I started like he inspired me to start I
don't have toys but like decorating my
space with [__] that's meaningful to me
and it just makes you feel better coming
into the room yes like it really makes a
difference than just having a stark yeah
yeah that's just real so like I was
saying I got a toy room like yeah I had
like my little I would grow poor [__] so
I could have my first toy I kept in my
whole life I still got Michael Keaton
Batman the best Batman the only one and
uh
I know I have kids in a spindle income I
made a toy room and it is incredible bro
I just started my little twitch section
I'm like I just don't use it so it's
it's good to hear like you know you
liked the imagination's there and like
it's open that's what I told him like
this episode's gonna be fun bro like I'm
excited for this episode most of my
friends are like that too keep their
imagination up collect toys comic books
cards yeah yeah rosin yeah rosin uh I
have homies that collect rosin and let
it sit like wine and like yo this is six
months and this is four months and this
is batch one oh God does that mean
anything to them all dabbing that's fine
I guess like what do you want me to say
is it is it supposed to like get better
with time sometimes it's separate I
don't know it separates the terpenes
will separate but you mix it back up
what was it waiting for all right I know
people are strict with their
temperatures and I'm very very on on top
of all that [__] there's temps and all
that stuff my homies are bougie [__]
[__] we need it I'm a lazy rosin
smoker but I need to the bougie guys to
keep me on point I used to be too man do
you dunk your nail and clean it every
time uh no see I clean it before I start
to smoke so that's what you should do
let us sit then clean it before but
that's what I used to do my boys would
clean it right after you hit it every
time you clean it right dunk it every
time bam boom yeah no when I lived in
New York Deb culture didn't exist so
when did this start in your world when
did it start I mean it existed in New
York back what 2013 14 and all that for
me thanks but um you know we were
smoking [__] dirt [__] [__] that look
like crap back in those times we didn't
know what the [__] we were smoking I
probably got more bronchitis from
smoking terrible rosin in the beginning
you know what I mean so I'm happy to see
where it is now oh and that goes wrong
how do you feel about like the just the
current state you have your freedom as a
human now like what's what's it like in
New York with the weed now
is
I don't want to say terrible a lot of
people are making very good money in New
York I'm not mad at the people that have
the flower and they're making them when
I'm mad at the consumer in New York
sometimes
um and again not to step on anybody's
toes I just feel like the normal
consumer in New York just wants to smoke
the same thing over and over again if
it's purple and if it has a candy smell
I wanted and I don't want anything else
and there's [__] 500 million thousand
new genetics every day why do we want to
smoke the same purple candy [__] I don't
know
I don't know it sounds like me it kills
me like you guys killing me
you guys are killing me there's so much
good [__] out there you guys with the
same [__] that looks purple it's all
just purple that's all that matters man
that's for them to the point like out
here where you can kind of just freely
go and walk in
um I'm a [__] traitor I I lived in La
for three years yeah I'm a Trader I've
lived in L.A for three years so when I
come back gotcha I'm I'm getting put on
like oh this is New York now I'm like
you mean to tell me the [__]
Arabs and boys at the deli shop then put
out the hard-working black man on the
corner he can't sell sweet no more
because y'all think well you know
selling everything I'm not mad at
anybody I'm just telling the stories
guys I'm just saying it's like it's
crazy in New York now you know everybody
just wants to Candy the smell the purple
smell or they're getting out beat by the
[__] deadlies and [__] because
they're selling the ace for thirty
dollars forty dollars thirty dollars you
know most people are snobs I'm working
man can't sell it eight for sixty
dollars in New York unless you got that
Community people that know what's the
fire is and what they want to smoke in
their Turf hunting and you know it's
sick it pisses me off see it pisses me
the opportunity I haven't bought a pound
of wheat except for that one time Fool's
Gold a pound away I used to buy a pound
to sit on it for like a week or two
smoke it bought a pound of weed now a
year and a half
no fire clean OG I only buy the same oh
my god oh just the gas it varies from
Skywalker to Lemon to Venom back and
forth I'm not mad at having a good OG on
the side at all times I'm not mad at
that at all times dude but if it's that
one candy strain only into it you can't
do it you need options it's like yo I
ate Sweet Tarts for eight years straight
like bro eat something else
yeah I agree
I was reading today talking about New
York City they just bought two robo dogs
I saw mayor Adam smiling next to that
goddamn
smile like a [__] with that dog
with that funny leg it's so weird having
funny legs I'm like yeah I'm just gonna
jump over that fool they got uh trackers
where if you're trying to flee in a car
they hit you with the tracker the dog
will no no separate separate police
investment this is RoboCop three yeah
when they started killing Nuns with
swords can't do that I'm not into it man
uh just like looking at it today uh
early in the morning at like 10 a.m my
brain was just like don't look at this
don't even take this in like this is
disgusting to look at and I'm scared for
the people in New York that had to
actually look at that [__] and take it
in every day because it looks [__]
weird it looks janky you know at least
make it look Pleasant like that [__]
Sophia that got the um what's her name
Sophia some [__] she's like the first AI
oh she looks like a human that's yeah at
least look it is scary but at least make
her look Pleasant all right
it then look like a lady at the store
but I don't want to get tricked like
that what is it machine how do you say
that what's that Messina you're putting
me on it some some terrible movie where
some white guy falls in love with a
robot and then she stabs him in the back
and then I just spoiled the whole movie
for you
yeah you know it's terrible we don't
want those kind of women's walking
around that look good but they're robots
it's not that far oh it's not that far
off yeah it's totally recall Total
Recall is real close but the good one
with Arnold Schwarzenegger the bad one
right yeah that's the only one I know
that's our new one it's a new one like
you said I'm not receiving this in my
brain I don't want this that's what I
did to that movie so real quick I know
we got mad notes I just gotta ask I'm a
uh fanatic Super Fan you know of
Seinfeld you know so you're wondering
about all 50 of my names and one of my
one of my names is Larry David 420.
so uh back in the day again me and the
boys we loved creating funny names the
AOL names the PSN names or whatever so
Mitch my partner
dark dark skin his uh one of his PSN
names was the black Brad Pitt love it
back when we were kids and um I guess
when I found uh love and Larry David I
was like all right I need I need a nice
white boy name I'm Larry [__] David
420 just you know added that because
when you're online you're friends yeah
you want to Clan up you want to Clan up
yeah so you want to put a name at the
end so my R tag was 420. yeah so you're
a fan genuinely if you saw Larry David
in person are you approaching him up top
okay um a lot of people feel like I'm
like this nonchalant a nonchalant guy
doesn't give a [__] about anyone no not
that but I will Fan Boy Over Larry [__]
David for sure that's not what I mean I
mean like oh you know Larry David's
personality like do I wanna oh that part
about it oh yeah I don't give a [__]
okay then you don't care all these rap
[__] all these actor [__] I bother
all the [__]
don't know me I'm coming up to you and
I'm going to make a fool out of myself
or you're gonna tell me that you like my
music either way either way it's great I
don't lose anything I go home and tell
shorty yo this [__] disrespect me they
didn't know me oh well stop listening no
I'm not gonna do that it's cool can you
think of an instance where you like
where this happened where you saw
somebody that you're super stoked Bob
you just kind of ran up on them like
okay again a lot of people think I'm not
in line I don't care about people but I
I saw Joe one time the singer Joe I
Wanna Know What or you know oh
yeah all right
um Joe yeah that's like one of his
classic uh introductions for winning
songs whatever yeah so many dope songs
he's amazing he's better than R Kelly
whatever
I saw Joe at the airport one day on
those train things and I was just like I
gotta bother this [__] nobody knows who
he is right now I do I'm bothering him I
was like Joe you killed the theme song
on power I'm so happy you're still out
here killing it what are you about to do
he's like going to Vegas got a show you
know he was happy to come up to me I
didn't buy them for a picture I don't do
that but you know I bothered them not
for pictures yeah well that's nice
because usually it's like people
probably get really annoyed with the
like it's kind of like uh because an
autograph is something personal a
conversation is something personal but
when people just want a picture they
just come they only want those little
likes that they're going to get off five
years ago it was cool now it's like are
you using me for a [__] picture yeah
that's what I mean I get it but some
people because at my my end because we
do meet and greets some people want to
take a picture but like I don't want to
take your time up bro I just want to say
I love you [__] and they leave because I
don't want to bug you so much
or are you like
my boy we're working like I found those
people and I don't associate with those
anymore
I can't tell who's it's art it's hard
it's so hard dude
legendary bay area yes yeah when Apple
sneezes he's does scatting so when you
do that he's the man for that yeah
he'll do it every time I love it it is
foreign
okay so oh sorry Larry David I got a
question in reality like if it you got
to think of everything which fictional
character you gotta be your neighbor and
your homie Leon from curved or Kramer
they're both gonna mooch off you so get
that out of the way
that's a [__] up question it is right
that's a [__] up question man I
thought about it but I'm gonna ask him
that tomorrow I hope his reaction that's
a [__] up question bro it's hard huh
because they're both gonna eat your [__]
and walking unannounced well
all right recent we'll just go with the
recent memory I was catching up on curb
maybe a week ago I had [__] covid uh
two weeks ago I just bounced back this
is like my second day outside I [__]
was watching curb catching up on the new
seasons because I haven't seen him and
this dude Leon's had some slick [__] he
said to Larry
because Larry was in a private jet to go
on uh whatever and he said just just
have me add me on as your luggage
I don't wanna just just look at me as
your luggage for the plane
and I said wait a minute if a friend
really came up to me and said I want to
go on a trip with you just look at me as
your luggage I might get convinced to
say yes but if he said just let me come
with you
and and buy me no but if you you tricked
me and said luggage I'm like yeah so
I'ma pick Leon because he tricked he
tricked Larry into you know that's
smooth as [__] it's it is I'm your
luggage I'm not gonna say anything I'm
not here but also you're coming with me
it's been eight years okay we just moved
in never left he's
he really is but then again Kramer does
cool [__] too yeah Kramer he does know
it's a lot of fools he's got a Tony
Award oh he had one yeah yeah that's I
love that you know what I'm saying not
many people have talked to that just
start talking [__] about science that's
my real thought out answer it's bad it's
real bad yeah yeah also what do you
think about that last episode of
Seinfeld I don't remember I don't
remember I haven't seen it
10 12 years I haven't seen in 10 12
years
it was always um something my cousin was
watching
um and I was just kind of mad that he
was watching it the whole time I'm a kid
yeah I like her more I was a kid you
know when seinfo was going on so I
didn't understand all the jokes it was
just like why is my older cousin
watching this [__] dry [__] all the
time
but Seinfeld's kind of clever Elena's
kind of hot Kramer reminds me of my
weird ass and then uh George yeah so it
kind of came together as I got older but
I didn't really get into it get into it
then when curb hit I was like no this is
amazing I gotta go back a little bit but
yeah I'm more curved than Seinfeld all
right I get that so uh I love watching I
love that I know we're doing crazy talk
right now but hopefully I understand
what we're saying and if you don't it's
okay it's just maybe you go watch this
[__]
um curbed I'm trying to put it at the
first maybe four episodes are mad dry
and they take a minute to build yeah you
know that HBO camera gets better the
second season it does right it was
darkest [__] like oh Sopranos you just
started watching Sopranos
one second season now all right I just
started second season yeah do you like
how Larry David's holding The Sopranos
DVD where's my Sopranos DVD I don't know
if you got the surprise it's not a
spoiler but in Sopranos they're on the
TV like that looks like you and it's
Larry David and and uh that's an episode
of curbed and Sopranos are like look
what's like you oh I love [__] [__]
like that oh bring it back full circle
uh Universe match of Worlds Multiverse
hopping
I mean HBO they're just making money oh
that's your water too oh cool cool cool
is it cold and [__] it's cold you know
cold war is bad is it bad for you it's
bad for me especially my tainted throw
Paws really does it really do that I
mean all right uh I don't know all the
signs behind it but cold water isn't
necessarily doing your body more than
warm water warm water actually your body
uh reacts to better I don't know all the
signs and then outs of it damn I really
don't want you no more I don't but I'm
[__] a grandma with that [__] I'm
accustomed to it I don't even care about
cold water I'll play basketball and
still not go after the cold water I'd be
like give me some more
that's how I felt in high school like oh
I made money if I like go get water
that's cold yeah I forgot all the
science behind it but the warm water
definitely hits your throat better I can
see that I can see that it's like
drinking teas man yeah all right Marty
let's
can you educate me a little bit because
our fan base is a little bit younger
they're all super into Flatbush Zombies
and stuff yeah when did you guys really
like when was the moment or the little
stretch where it really felt like damn
we're really taken off from where we
started from taking off from where we
started from the moment
um I'm a terrible talker and a terrible
texter so if it takes me a second to get
there take me a second all right um we
uh
2000 our first video Thug Waffle is the
moment everything changed our life
changed
um that was I think January 2012. but we
put the Thug Waffle single out in 2011
we hopped on um Eric the architect boom
he makes all our beats in the group and
he raps on him too we hopped on one of
his albums as well on a song called
sleep
and we like wrapped on caps lock M.I.A
we wrapped on uh Gucci Gucci creation
and this is uh on our Tumblr we just
released this on Tumblr in 2011 and 10.
we had this crazy tumbler that I
I would get us canceled today it was the
worst piece of [__] Tumblr you've ever
[__] seen in your life like a lot of
the memes that you see today we were we
already had that because you know when
you're a kid and you first get on your
computer and you learn what Google is
and you're like [__] 10 and 11.
you're like I'm saving every picture in
the universe and I'm full I'm putting
forward thank you warm water yeah since
we were like [__] kids beginning in
Internet dial-up era we had folders of
folders of folders of everything so
every picture celebrity sneakers [__]
Wicked [__] and we just put it to use on
that Tumblr and uh we got banned from
Tumblr and we had to make a new one
and that's when we were like okay we're
gonna make some T-shirts we're gonna
brand this [__] out and we're gonna
start releasing music [__] it man that's
how that started yeah these are your
homeboys that you just grew up with grew
up with yeah Eric was already rapping
making beats he was in a group before us
and um
having him around
it was just an inspiration and like kind
of like oh wow I can do this oh wow this
is obtainable oh wow I've seen Eric
go from this to this meaning like
beginner steps to better than Kanye West
to me and um just being around that kind
of growth and being around that is
inspiring and helped me say oh [__] I
can pick up a pen and get in there
because we used to make these silly ass
songs like uh for fun yeah like get
drunk the guys and the girls are out
Eric you're not doing anything serious
right so let us joke off and make these
silly ass songs like this one track
called Diddy juice when like Soraka just
came out
we were like what the [__]
the [__] alcohol but what the [__] is a
rock did he juice okay let's try it
we're not [__] awkward kids dude
super nine titty juice that was that was
the chorus man and we all [__] make
dumbass song called Diddy juice I hopped
on this one song called chilling in the
club it was like we used auto-tune we're
like [__] 16 17 just making jokes and
having fun and that actually became a
profession
and really started wrapping your ass off
yeah yeah and then you that's just
insane to me that because to me like
Brooklyn is flat wash for people I don't
realize is a part of Brooklyn right
there in the center of Brooklyn right
and like Brooklyn to me is one of the
most legendary hip-hop places on Earth
obviously it's not the most top
rappers of all time I was just telling
the lady that does my hair like how
important Biggie Smalls is to our
community our culture like he's
literally a cartoon character at this
point not in a bad way it's just like he
is Bugs Bunny or he is an idol he is a
mascot yeah he's Immortal and I was just
telling her like you know
he was the first person to make it not
the first person to make it look cool
but really the first person to make it
look cool you know when you think of
Biggie Smalls you want the Jesus Piece
he was the first person rocking out you
want the Coogies you went Tim's I'm
wearing Tim's right now yeah you know
what I mean it's like he painted the
picture for us he put the
he was shooting million dollar videos
like he's the first one that we saw from
Brooklyn to actually do it on a big
level in Yachts like you know what I
mean so it's like
being around and then Jay-Z topped that
but yeah Biggie Smalls was like that
first one to like show us in New York
like oh you can live large you can do
this [__] you know I mean there's
obviously Legends ODB is a legend but
you know Wu-Tang isn't known for like
the flashy [__] but he smells in Bad Boy
showed us the flashy [__] kind of type
[__] yeah yeah I was just telling she's
from California she don't know [__]
about [__] so I'll just put like culture
but yeah I forgot what your point was
what were you saying well like coming up
you're kind of that generation after
that whole Legendary Run of like
Brooklyn rap did you kind of still feel
that was it like damn we could do this
we're from from [__] burger and put
that shirt right in the name like
yeah so special to have Flatbush in the
name for real but um
I mean I knew what I could do and I knew
what we were gonna do because I knew
that we were living a different life
than the normal Brooklyn cat or the
normal Flatbush person and after seeing
Wiz khalifas and Tyler creators in Naomi
ASAP I was like oh [__] I know we can do
this [__] because we're bringing
something new to the table like those
guys do a whole new lifestyle that
people in Brooklyn don't know about
which is the Psychedelic lifestyle and
being yourself type [__] and not caring
about at least a zombie name right
because yeah normally you might not
think that that's how that would have
come about but I saw an interview you're
describing that I think Vlad that
psychedelics thank you for the kind of
symbology yeah poison but yeah continue
rebirth uh is where the name come from
yeah so what what was that experience
like what what happened to bring that
about
man I
psychedelic trips
um Regular trips in your mind where
you're trying to figure out what this
life is and where you're going
um rebirthing being born again
um all these things are synonymous with
our life like I'm a church boy my
grandma's a pastor so I always have some
kind of weird magic in me I guess or
some kind of weird energy I guess I get
it from her
um so I was always a little weird kid or
a different kid and Meech
this dude I met him in third grade he
was a [__] encyclopedia and he's like
he was like one of the smartest kids I
ever know it's like encyclopedia can
tell you everything about any animal
[__] like that's how he was in third
grade like the [__] genius so like we
always were [__] like weird kids or
whatever
and I guess the uh
the LSD and the mushrooms kinda
put some hair in our chest
not not like uh because you know you can
take [__] shrooms and ass and nothing
can happen to you or you won't have a
breakthrough or you know it's just like
a night party yeah but um
you know we thought we were [__]
magicians
all of our friends we thought we were
magicians like my other homie Issa from
The Underachievers
we thought we were [__] magicians and
we knew legitimate magic we thought we
could manifest anything
we thought that we were [__]
Gods amongst men's and people seen that
and they just gravitated towards us and
wanted to know what the [__] you got on
right now what do you mean you're
manifesting something
what do you mean you're
making [__] happen like we just make
[__] happen just like whatever like poor
kids hustling every day just making [__]
happen whatever you wanted like say the
goal was we need 200 by the end of the
day to do this thing and to go somewhere
and do this we would make [__] disappear
type [__] not [__] but we would just
make it happen or whatever the goal was
like I remember
I'm probably off of what the [__] you
were saying but I remember that I think
the Giants were gonna win the Super Bowl
in 2008 or something and mean Easter
just like
dosed out on whatever drugs laying in
the [__] staircase like our life is
gonna change if the Giants win this
[__] Super Bowl and that was one of
our manifestations and all year when
were they beat the Patriots that's 2008
that's how important it was it was the
[__] Patriots yeah that was the real
one so we we put so much energy like yo
if they just win this [__] our life is
gonna change that they did win our life
did change but it didn't happen
instantly but that was just like an exam
a small example of how
not crazy we were but just like how much
we believed in just manifestation and
just speaking things in life at that
time 2008 like what the [__] are we
thinking well I'm 18 17. that's when I
had my first kid too so just like really
yeah life was just changing like we were
growing up like
I went through the exact same thing and
um I guess the whole Born Again thing
it's just like seeing life um with no
Veil
yeah just like seeing life for what it
is not expecting [__]
um not putting too much judgment out
there
um understanding you know you're just a
small part of this puzzle this energy
this field that you know everything
borrows from each other and we're just
regenerating
all that kind of [__] um so that's kind
of where the born-again thing comes from
like uh all right I see life for what it
really is now
let's [__] go now it's time to start
the game of life and that's when I got
this tattoo I was like 16 and it just
says life on it and then it used to like
walk around
um talking about the game of life and
this is the game of life because I have
to play the game of life and we had
these [__] beats or whatever me and
uh Easter from none Achievers and we
call these the life beads
in the beginning it's in order to get
your life bead you had to come hang out
with us and it was like a fake cold or
some [__] I would say like a fake cult
a cult in the hood in the project
there's a fake coat you come over how
much money you got okay
I'm taking that you want to smoke weed
too okay don't worry about that okay you
want to learn about this all right we're
rambling today okay you need a place to
cut School you need a place to do this
what do you so it's like we're giving
back to our community but we're also
taking from the community because we
need money to buy weeds and drugs and
[__] and so you know but we're also
teaching people how to be free and not
like be stuck in that mindset of the
hood or like you know doesn't have to be
the hood but just a funny bad mindset so
we used to give out these live beats one
of the homies was so jealous that about
this new thing we were on he didn't want
to have nothing to do with it you know
people were switching sides people
thought we were [__] crazy in the
hood and did you watch the secret is
that what no no that's the worst part
about it not the worst part but that's a
funny [__] about it like a year into
this [__] mom's like yo there's a
[__] book about this [__]
damn so the drugs just put you onto this
information
the drugs and just like I said it's just
so much stuff like I'm a church boy
[__] Marlin or Easter sorry he says
just [__] Issa he Isa is the [__]
from the hood that went to the white boy
school with all the genius kids
to Mitch [__] eclectic too like you
know what I mean like all of my friends
are [__] weird and different and we
just put everything together
yeah that's they start looking at you
like you're real [__] crazy when you
start talking yeah
and and that's why I was so it goes back
to what you were saying
um and that's why now it was so hard
because it wasn't hard but that's why
when we came out
the core New York culture
didn't understand it
because they're like okay these [__]
is running with gang members [__] are
doing inside the 30s [__] doing this
getting money blah blah but they're
talking about
acid and shrooms and this nigga's hairs
died and this [__] got cold teeth
please you make it was just like a
[__] mindful everything was just a
mindful because they can understand how
we can be these people we'll also be
those people because we're from Flatbush
so unique just being yourself yeah and
they didn't understand it they didn't
want to they didn't want to [__]
support it too much at first because
they it was weird it was different but
we had to do that to break the mold to
change the mold to help do with the
other guys that I was talking about was
doing you know I mean we had to do it we
had to be different because doing that
helped the whole [__] structure of
music and New York music and culture
change literally so I always tell people
I I died like Jesus
for the culture and to be because I was
the first one doing the color hair [__]
and all that weird [__] so
seen that that's the staple of being an
artist now just to have colored hair
just that alone makes me feel like oh I
had to die for y'all since because I'm
not [__] it wasn't so cool I'm good
but I'm not good I'm trying to get
better every day I'm not [__] future
rich or anything like that I'm trying to
come up still so I had to die so
everyone else can fly because I caught
all the Flack for being weird and all
that [__] yeah you know what I mean damn
why did it feel like that faded away and
now it had shifted into your favor
everything shifted in our favor like I
said Thug Waffle 2012 the video first
video woke up
I remember uh the spot called The Palace
it was my trap house and everyone was in
there we was having a party asked all
the girls asked all the guys what what
is this video gonna when we wake up
tomorrow what is this gonna what is this
video going to be a thousand views a
million everyone took their guesses I
think I said like 10 000 or something
I think meech said like over a million
because
it's like who we're nobody so it's like
to guess over a million it's funny as
[__] some people knew that night or that
week that this was gonna change our
lives and some people didn't I I didn't
I cared but I wasn't like it has to
change your life because who walks
around like I don't do that there's no
it has to do anything it's just like
we're doing we're moving and what we
gave is what we get so I never
put it that far I knew like I said I
knew it was different and it was going
to work because no one's seen it before
but I didn't know but I knew I didn't
know and man we woke up to like a
million views bro and vice uh we're
coming over tomorrow I'm like are you
coming over tomorrow
the to the Trap article if you go back
you look at the uh I got the mattress on
the floor
dude you got the mattress on the floor
we got the studio in the room
we take them to Target like here's where
I steal my diapers you know what I mean
like they came over the next day bro
who's this yeah it was instant Lana Del
Rey told MTV we're her favorite group
that same week it was just like what the
[__] what just happened yo just happened
but like you said it's kind of like the
break the mold thing yeah it's different
it's just it's just different because
you have to be like I died I'm Jesus on
the cross because if you think about it
but trust me we get our [__] do I'm
here talking to you guys
all of our friends artists respect
everyone respect so we have our dude
it's just like we still have more dude
to do God damn it we gotta break [__]
through we haven't broken through yet to
me so oh that's how you feel oh yeah oh
but that's you know I mean I I should
feel that way I hope so because if I
felt if I felt cozy then I'm just
chilling all right that's true yeah if
you never feel like you can get bigger
and do better yeah so what's that next
step real quick then if you think if
you're like I haven't broke through yet
what do you think that's gonna be the
next step is uh
coming back and collecting the tabs we
haven't put a flapper zombie album out
in about four years I think three to
four years okay it was a you know we did
the Beast Coast 2019 we did the EP 2020
we we did the vacation now 2018.
we haven't did it uh another full group
album since 2020 pretty much what is uh
Gloria is bad is that Gloria is there
recordings that is
that's the name of the label
at first we was rocking out with
Electric Kool-Aid records but we
couldn't you know Electric Kool-Aid
um and um you know the Kool-Aid didn't
work out so we couldn't get that so we
switched it up to the Glorious dead
recordings gosh Gloria's dead Grateful
Dead you know what I mean borrow from
that aesthetic yeah and now was it in
February that I studied posts I'm going
out to LA I'm doing my first solo
performance
yeah so
um
Mitch put his album October Eric put uh
EP out earlier that year and then Eric's
gonna put his album out maybe later this
year or next year and then I'm putting
my album amount on uh April 21st so we
have some solo missions to run before we
spin the block again and remind
everybody what the [__] it is so that's
the way he put that yeah let's go cause
I mean yeah it makes you guys stronger
as a group to go out as individuals and
just put out your own stuff right yeah
we've been doing this for so long and uh
me and Mitch didn't really have a solo
catalog like that just a couple of
Records here or there you know Eric like
I said Eric was always a artist before
us and he has solo you know so it has to
be done we're older now it's time to so
the reason they shouldn't have been done
like as far as going into the studio to
actually make it like did you enjoy it
more or less than being able to like
collaborate with your friends I'm always
gonna enjoy being around my friends more
um but
the clarity the um
just the Fulfillment that I got from
making this project from the solo
project is um
yeah you can't really put a number on
that [__] love without conditions April
21st right yeah yeah the 24th oh damn
right now it's my kid's birthday
beautiful wait happy birthday
happy birthday cam yeah uh and the
artwork I love the artwork it seems like
it's right in line with the whole yeah
uh the artist uh one artist that that's
talking that's Daniel he heated the
cover I was like please please please I
need it thank you thank you thank you
did you give him direction to go in or
did he just come up with that well
actually
um it originated as a Valentine's Day
card that um hope Lord was gonna give to
a lucky lady and
um yeah
he was like
I was like I need that and um you made
new Valentine's Day cards guys so that
was gonna be one of the movie we ended
up making new ones I need that
you gave it to me
and then I had to ask you know Daniel
can I have it for the cover yeah
how would you describe it it's an
illustration
of like
Bliss love joy happiness and growth yeah
love that yeah it's full of you I can't
really talk what a great explanation
oh people think I'm a weirdo I'm telling
you people think I'm weird but I'm
special
uh I everybody said I was weird because
I can't say what they used to call me I
was in third grade because I like we
used to make collages remember that I
talked about this recently right it's
the Marilyn Manson thing we talked who
do we talk I like Marilyn Manson and I'm
in a full Mexican town and fools are
just talking [__] and I grew up on
classic [__] because my mom only grew up
in a classic rock and my grandpa only on
doo-wop so I don't know
Tony Tony and everybody's like you don't
know who Tony Jones in the first grade
and everybody made fun of my ass dude
but like it's hard to be weird those
fools grow up dope as hell that's what
I've come to see when you're actually
yourself yeah that's what I'm saying
what do we what are we doing it for
we're not doing it for ourselves
yeah yeah that's that's the message
April 21st is your first actual solo
debut yeah yeah I had a lot of fun um
writing because I I just like stayed in
my room and um was depressed and [__]
and wrote it everything and then yeah
is that because it sounds like I mean
your music sounded like when you first
came out it's like really fun and kind
of silly and like upbeat so that's not
the normal place you like right from
we definitely rap from depression and
heartache and if I have a zombie world
but the the the the New Perspective that
I'm writing from is just more just not
not unless we always do storytelling but
this is just more like emotions and free
thoughts that are um
kind of reminders to myself of places
where I have to grow on or things I need
to remember to to have Clarity to move
forward
um remembering things like my mom
passing away traumas
um [__] like that yeah so that's what
this album you know that did for me
helped me stay in that place remember
things and mantras and [__] like that
that's really all it is it's just
there's no like wasted lines some just
every line it's just like mean something
wow I love that specifically that's how
it's supposed to be really I mean yeah
yeah that's what the Project's supposed
to mean to the artist like you know you
get different answers and different
contexts about like oh I was trying to
do the radio the sound for here and the
sound for that people this time for that
people and this one is art collection of
different sounds for everybody this is
my real thoughts and important things I
want to put out I want to make money I
want people to like it but
I just had to like make something for me
you know now as far as people you did
collaborate with producers other artists
you want to talk about that power's
Pleasant Eric dark Elliott
um Tyler Tyler Dobbs
um we got currency on there
we got the homie Cole train on there
he's from UK badass
killer killer he singing skills is
amazing he writes Beautiful music man
he's up there with Frank to be with
writing
um Coltrane we got Jay Gray another UK
artist so got meech on there The
Underachievers nice oh yeah and then you
said you're circling back to a group
album because I see you're gonna we'll
get there eventually there's a festival
coming up in Utah Utah it's gonna be fun
Utah throws up for us heavy they're one
of our top markets for sure yeah yeah
happy have you thought that that uh
smokers club show was sick those Utah
kids really different
because someone I've had bad experience
in Utah that's I've only been there with
the police with the police yeah
that will put a stain on the yeah yeah
I've never got to it's like fully like
get out of the car besides being told to
[__] that's the only experience I
had in Utah [__] that she was whack
um so you have that's how I feel about
Canada
I thought Kansas was legal
I got caught in the border with some
[__] Rising one time I was like sick
and we were just crossing the border I
wasn't even smoking and [__] to be
honest it was just in my pocket
rosin they tripped off of yeah this is
in the early Rising times like 2013 too
so oh yeah you were in trouble yeah I
was in trouble yeah yeah that might as
well been I remember I remember going to
court they're like
so what scientists made this it's a
scientist [__] it's just weed
suppressed it's hard
what they thought it was in the lab with
a chemist or something I'm surprised
they even knew what it was like they
really didn't they really didn't it took
them a minute to really
figure out what it was and build that
yeah because it was the Early Times yeah
it was in the middle of a border in
Canada somewhere yeah I was trying to
describe to him we used to try to go
over to Canada from Buffalo and they
were not having it they did not want us
there no at all they're stretching the
car every single time
[__] the car the car is evil I'm never
doing it yeah
not cool yeah
now someone wanted to ask you completely
unrelated I saw you post about an indigo
lifestyle
Indigo lifestyle I posted that yeah okay
I don't know if that means something new
that's something my mom tried to like
put me on in like a whole list oh this
you remember this is yeah the first time
I heard that terminology was from Issa
he one day we were cutting school we
were in the [__] uh in his bathroom
that was I love smoking in bathrooms by
the way really fun they get boxed quick
oh they're small but yeah that of the
car yeah and he was like talking tell me
about this term Indigo it was like kids
that have like a second nature uh kind
of psychic Vibes good at manifesting
like we were like we're random [__] like
that
um that's the first time I ever heard it
yeah you know it's not something I
[__] swear by I live by I don't think
I've ever even said it in a song I might
have said it once but my partners do
that's something more that they um ride
what I resonate with I I still like the
theory and respect it and believe in it
yeah I actually looked it up it's a
theory that sounds like there's a group
of souls that are incarnated it's like a
oh I believe that a class 100 and their
auras are indigo the color indigo that
part and they have certain traits of uh
like being like highly sensitive to
being able to like manifest because I've
what we can talk about but yeah my
grandma you know my grandma has this my
grandma has dreams about [__] before it
happens and it's very accurate you know
because she told me when I was like 14
because he's just scared the [__] I
talked about this like two nights ago
I've talked about it before so it's okay
to talk about anyhow
Rob had many dreams that come to life
and I've called them out before it
happens like Final Destination and
bounced
and uh
like one of them my vice principal I had
a dream like I just saw this my vice
president Mr Anderson he's also I was in
the third grade he's cool you know when
you're a kid you're like yeah that guy's
tight when you before you know people
suck yeah you know because if he's a
nice team like he's a great guy that's
all I get to see
oh
yeah like I told you earlier my asthma
is already [__] so that's really cool
yeah that's another one did you say
asthma Tourette's
food
here we go
big Tourette's all right here we go yo I
have a dream Mr Anderson's place is
playing like a guitar he's on stage and
the full grabs his chest Falls over and
a bunch of people crowd around him oh my
God that was crazy as hell wake up I
live two houses away from what my
grandma does two houses away from my
school I got to wake up at like five
minutes for his class it was amazing wow
get up and just walk across the street
and uh I walk in right I'm in third
grade I walk in
and I see two teachers I know and
they're both crying and I was like what
the hell is that
straps I keep walking oh my God yeah
yeah get to class and my teacher has
she's on her desk like rubbing her eyes
with Kleenex and I'm like what the hell
happened
and then she sits everybody down talks
to us and lets us know Mr Anderson died
I have a heart attack while playing with
his band farmer said wow he went out on
top though
yeah he was jamming out I was like and
all his homies were there so it was like
it was sad for them but like kind of
tight every one of your homies is with
you that's pretty awesome but that's
like sex
dying during sex that's like yeah that's
that's you know all your home it's like
sex wow not that your homies are there
every time you have sex but it's just an
intimate experience it's the people you
love okay okay
yeah and some experienced people you
love is like sex
[Laughter]
that's true though my dad would have
preferred to go out on stage than with
some cancer for damn sure yeah no that's
yeah of course
um
but yeah whatever that was called you
have some Indigo capabilities that
shit's crazy as hell but I've told him
before like dodging that fool with all
those bugs like oh I see him bounce and
then it happened like found destination
so when I saw that as a kid I'm like am
I insane yeah because guys are insane
they're dying yeah politician was it
ruined everybody
is like oh logs on the freeway I'm done
that's how you're supposed to be it's
like yeah you should have some good you
gotta have some intuition man yeah you
have to yeah but uh that's how I thought
I didn't know there was a term for it
yeah but I always felt weird as hell and
then my grandma was like no I have those
dreams she has a little book in Spanish
yeah she's a book in Spanish it tells
you what your dreams mean very accurate
you're right a dream that your teeth are
breaking I've had that before yeah I
forgot what that means I've heard it
represents like insecurity it's oh [__]
she told me it's like you're insecure
with somebody that you're living with
because it's new and you're not sure who
you've and I just moved in with my
grandma my grandpa because my other
Grandma I can see that it was the week
that my grandma died so I was like I
feel weird with me and my grandpa just
by ourselves when you see burritos and
watch football but now we gotta talk
you know we're the only people in the
house now you know what I mean so like
so they had dreams and all that shit's
very uh it's like the next week's show
after The Simpsons it's like the next
you know it's just previewing [__] that
might
happen or like careful it is one time uh
I woke up and
caught something
you woke up and caught something yeah
yeah yeah what were we having a dream
about
um don't know what the dream was about
but meech was um like dribbling a
basketball
and he was staying over me
and he went like this I swear to God I
seen it happen before it happened and he
went and threw me the ball
but I was sleeping and dreaming that it
was happening and I caught it like this
and he was like bro what the [__]
how'd you do that I swear to God
so you've had that [__] happen before
too there yeah one time um I was like in
bed
ex-girlfriend and um we're sleeping
her sister pops into the room and then I
wake up out of nowhere and I jump up and
I threw the pillow at her and I called
her a [__] I don't know why I just knew
someone was coming in the room and that
now we were sleeping in my dream but I
didn't know it was her but then I woke
up and it was actually a person I threw
a pillow at them and called him a [__]
I don't know why I was sleeping and I
was dreaming that someone was entering
the room and yeah I've done stupid [__]
oh I almost slapped the old lady on the
airplane because I was
I was so happy I didn't catch that
[__] man I've been in so much
trouble the 60 year old sweet old lady
bro I'm like sleeping dreaming about
some [__] is fighting me and I'm like
that
and she dodged that [__] bro no she dies
that [__] and she was like so like um uh
I don't know the word but she was
apologetic I should have been apologetic
but she's like oh my God okay
okay
she saw that you were asleep yeah yeah
yeah
[__] man
who was she that she she was 60 years
old are you okay dodged you yeah and
then she was like are you okay oh my God
no I'm sorry sometimes in my sleep I
wake up and start swinging and one time
I
Woke up had my hands around
um my girlfriend
this is terrible quotes
me
I woke up
a couple of six-year-old woman she said
sorry me
[__] me oh man it's like these crazy
dreams I hate that [__] bro
I've definitely woke up yeah yeah it's
scary to sleep next to me no way it's
terrible that sucks that's terrible my
mother my stepbrother Sleepwalk slept
walk slap walk
used to sleepwalk my box sounds stupid
nobody ever got to that conundrum before
I don't know if I've ever happened you
just talk to yourself
all right
he's okay with me talking about it yeah
he would have different personalities
when he would Sleepwalk [__]
like you're talking you would come in
and talk as another human nice and say
this is my name this is what I do yeah
Wide Awake like what do you what are you
doing
um
and we would Shake him awake and he'd be
start crying he's a little kid yeah and
there was like a I'll go too crazy and
do it but the full head characters wow
and he can split [__] dead exactly dad
asleep sometimes his eyes completely
closed but most of the time Eyes Wide
Open so like what's up we'll go to sleep
why are you why are you awake still
hi we're going to be doing this and like
what the hell like Chucky doll oh [__]
out of me damn
I suck my door like he was Pizzazz I
don't say that I just leave my door
locked a sleepwalker can get in the
locked room though
yeah I heard for sure but he was he was
if I'm 15 he's eight oh hell no yeah
he's a kid so it's not like I'm gonna
kick him I got some creepy he was creepy
yeah because he had a little voice yeah
that's what I was saying like I throw
pillows and get him awake you know when
he was going the hallway I'd be like oh
I throw pillow at him from the from the
couch I did it many times yeah I'm sorry
but yeah I did the old people I used to
take like valerian root I feel like
induced dreams to like try to help
astral project and [__] like that like
trying to induce I gotta hear all this
wait so you astral project in dreams
like get to a place where you're almost
tired enough but still awake to get
super relaxed like a force
state of relaxation to almost be able to
actually project here I've only done it
like three or four times
um
by the time I started hitting the road
and wrapping and [__] I had dreams
dreams disappear but you know it's hard
to get dreams you stopped getting Dreams
yeah
I used to do when I was younger you know
it's harder for me to dream now but you
know
it would be so fun I I remember there
was times I was I grow mad poor I didn't
do nothing uh so there'll be times like
yo tonight I'm gonna do this and I'd be
sitting there for like 10 minutes and I
remember the times I'd wake up like it
worked how did that work you know what
I'm saying like where am I gonna do
tonight I used to do it more time
sometimes I have lucid dreams oh I can
do whatever I want and I would jump like
the Hulk when you jump in the Grand
Canyon I feel so good when you jump in
the dream or you're flying it's
literally how it feels literally I
grabbed the ground all the time and I
throw myself from the ground like if
it's concrete if it's grass I grab that
[__] and I throw myself it's so fun
getting across town when you know you're
dreaming it's not you know I'm just
running away I'm running and then
jumping I'm leaving yes it's this
I'm older now it's so hard to get that
to that place but yeah I remember I'll
never forget those feelings no I'm it's
age stress too much thoughts being older
I don't know
once you get off this [__] you you will
all turn into dream Masters if you take
a [__] two week break your withdrawal
symptoms of the dreams
cinematic like action movie dreams oh
intense um breaks from weed and bloody
what intense intense like wake up your
heart is beating out your chest dreams
like I've always smoked we didn't have
those dreams lucky man man I wish I can
get stopped crazy State the week I
started dating my fiance
what the [__] did you say it only
happened twice in 11 years you're giving
me ideas yo it was fun because it's
boring I had insomnia as a kid so I'd be
sitting there just jumping off walls in
my head and bouncing buildings and [__]
you know yeah I'm so happy we could talk
to you about this yeah most people like
yeah man yeah I got you oh wait Mr
Anderson like yeah get the hell out of
here
wow so you can actually project in the
state of limbo uh yeah yeah being asleep
because the Valerian helps you get into
a deeper state of sleep I think and
helps your body relax too but so yeah
but what I don't get is like when you're
astral projecting you know you're asleep
right behind you
I remember like being in the crib
leaving through the window
and like my Building 21 floors so it's
like it's a it's a special to leave this
window it's the tallest building in
Flatbush so being in that I'll never
forget that like leaving the room going
out the window looking at the building
from this view going around Flatbush
Junction you know and then a little
self-control and don't know anything
else after that but yeah I never forget
that any more that you went further no
oh one time literally above um like uh
you know when that dude jumped out of
the [__] uh some red bull [__] where
he jumped and he was like floating or
some [__] yeah yeah it's like that view
yeah yeah
I won't say the whole day but I took I
used to take questions of my a lot of
mushrooms and I haven't since then but I
didn't know what it was I thought it was
insane for like a year but I took off
look down see my body yeah went through
my roof but it's like it opened like it
took like eight grams or some [__] yeah
like a curtain you know what I'm saying
you couldn't pay me to take eight grams
oh mushrooms you couldn't pay me to take
a grams at this point I don't know oh
okay that's scary to me at this point
I'm busy but back then I'm like yo let's
take me my girl we met she she's a
monster we would take this but I can
remember doing this and being above
myself looking down and being able to
feel that I'm still in my body but
knowing that I'm up
yo I shot off over my over my
neighborhood I could see cars so I'm
like am I tripping
or am I in another plane
you know what I mean like I'm on another
both
but really in another place because I
could see what the top of everyone's
house looked like yep and I shouldn't be
able to do that too much for your
imagination I mean it goes longer but I
shot off into space I saw this big
Sundial thing turning and then I got
scared I looked down that's crazy yeah I
saw the scare and it looked down and
when I looked down it went and I felt
like I hit my body wow and I was back on
my bed because it was Pitch Black no
music we both were just
sweating tripping she was laying right
next to me for like six hours we were
both having our own experience but the
next night I did it again we did eight
grams a game we're like nah did it work
go back it worked I talked to like four
or five people for I felt like months I
was up there man but I entered
I brought my girlfriend with me yeah
and then I'm like oh you know I'm just
tripping like yo is it real
I talked to all these people all it's a
long story but uh
I was walking above
people and they're like they can't see a
story door and we're just talking about
like should I use I should know and I
knew it so I remember back then like
what what are you talking about the guy
with the armor on like only stuff you
would know yeah but I didn't understand
did she know is she the same [__] or
what
so we come out six in the morning and
she's like you know we're trying to
drink water like that and that was
intense and we're still tripping a
little bit and she starts telling me and
she's like and then at one point you
grabbed me and she explained to every
person I just introduced her to and I'm
like say that all again and then she's
like yeah you said you were introducing
me to somebody
and that's exactly what I was saying
like this is my friend that I brought
from this plane like really cool wow and
I told her and then I was like come here
and I reached down to like like on a
stage you know you spotlight stuff yeah
that's I could see us on our bed that's
it
and then everything else was in the star
that Silver Surfer board but it was a
table remember we did a whole video on
this that's why it's kind of like yeah
I'm trying not to like go too into it
for people that's like all right I love
it you've seen it remember all this and
you can pinpoint I have all these
emotions every single thing everything
what it looks like I can have someone
draw that please get [__] everything we
need the comic book that's crazy well I
looked up the Sundial just based off how
he described it when I was editing the
video and he was like and I found an
image on Google and he's like well that
was it that was the Sunday same face
with the same symbols on it but he had
like a tongue out [__] and and it
started turning that's some [__] tied to
your heritage or something man
it was crazy
what if you did Like An ancestry and
found out you were like linked back to
that's like they're like you might be I
don't know say you get some media powers
from your your Villa I I don't know man
I don't even think it's I just feel like
yeah well this was high you guessed
finally after 365 dreams you got one
right you know what I mean
that's that's the other half of Is that
real or you just high as hell so I don't
know hey man I like things to sound
mythical especially there you go so I
like that could be cool
without mushrooms is the craziest [__]
that's why I wanted to ask yeah I
haven't been able to do it since I was
like 20 but you know you know life sucks
how much is like mushrooms or
psychedelics in general part of your
life your routine now you just take a
piece of a little chocolate bar and uh
well I mean we always just doing that
but now it's just you know it's so much
more accessible and it's everywhere so
you know I'm gonna take some mushrooms
to go see John Mayer oh nice yeah can
you wrap on mushrooms yeah made a lot of
the the beginning songs of acid I don't
know not mushrooms per se but I'm pretty
sure I could I never done it but I'm
pretty sure I could you can go in there
and record on acid I would I've never
done anything because you're like you
want to do like for me if I'm doing acid
I'm like
I need to have some goals that before I
do it so one of the goals is over
recording thing gotta make sure make a
song got a mission and that's and that's
like fun like a fun thing to do yeah you
know what answer sometimes because like
I said sometimes you take acid you're
not trying to kill yourself and get
reborn again yeah I'm not trying to take
for it to have the acid my [__] right
now let's bust some missions pop a tab
and keep it going so I can be functional
too that's why I'm a weird so when you
say Reborn
what do you mean what are you saying by
this like I saw some light and this
pulling a white coat got me yeah no no
okay so what do you mean by that like
reborn just re just reformatting your
brain yeah I I you know I'm reformatted
right now this is a whole new era of
zombie juice
it's gonna be holding error Flappy
zombies so you don't have to take the
drug to reform out all the time but in
those beginner stages
you know if you're already weird and you
take that stuff you're gonna reformat
you're gonna reformat that's real people
should really think about that and
consider it like when I started talking
all that [__] you're talking about like
manifesting stuff they were calling me
crazy and looking at me crazy I felt
like oh my iOS is kind of changing here
the way that I perceive the world
internally is different I'm reformatting
right but you can do it you can
deliberately do it and then you kind of
like bring about more information that
feeds into it that just helps you think
cleaning your karma is one yeah one part
of reformatting
like what do you mean by that cleaning
your karma like really assessing
bad things that you do that can come
back to you and like cleaning it up
going on a streak of doing good things
to knock it out or going through some
bad situations to feel the heat of it so
you can reformat that Karma and move on
a better basically that's one part to
reformatting I mean just this weird
little [__] like that
I always feel like after I do
psychedelics the next one day day or two
after I'm super clear-headed the world
is completely different I see what's
important and then it just but that's
reformatting because at some point you
get you get to a point of um you lose
sight of something that's how I feel
sometimes how was I not here all the
time like bro did you freak it's like
Peter Pan and you left Neverland or
something you're like you look familiar
man repeater right like that's how I
feel it I'll never change and then it
goes back I don't know it's a weird
feeling but after that mushroom trip
where me and my girlfriend I didn't take
streams for five years or four four and
a half exactly I don't have to [__]
micro dose or every day to think I feel
some kind of magic or something I don't
want to
I don't know if I understand it
necessarily I don't think I don't really
know if I understand it yeah like I
don't really know yo smell this weed
like I'm [__] high like are you yeah
it makes you feel a little different
though if it works for someone I'm happy
for them I just don't know if I
understand it exactly my English is cool
it's just I want to get high if I'm
going to take mushrooms we did micro
dosing once I'm like this is cool I
couldn't just do this to to do it I you
feel you always remember like oh yeah
mushrooms I forgot but it's cool I think
it helps people like that reformatting
because some people
I think mushrooms help with the
not mental disorders but mental
met like the wiring might be a little
off like you just don't see it you know
some people like make the biggest deal
out of nothing in case you take a step
back but they can fix someone else's
problem not their own yeah it's just I
feel like psychedelics I'm not preaching
here to go do psychedelics it's not a
commercial yes I feel like it it could
help you open up or do this but you
gotta want it though you gotta want it
though of course yeah of course you
can't just go in there thinking oh yeah
see Dumbo and elephants and [__] yeah
you know like it doesn't work yeah no
that's young and Dumbo where he's on
mushrooms basically he drinks he's all
tripping remember that everything about
hitting in all our Disney films in the
normal Edition films
maybe that was a weird feeling as a kid
sorry anyway my bad my bad besides
psychedelics and Dumbo and mushrooms you
know you know you have a single coming
out or that use a single dizzy Wow
featuring none Achievers east of none
she was produced it too nice yeah yeah
we used to live in the same building so
that's why we're always together yeah
could you imagine just being on the
floor hey I like your music
you know let's live it I mean it's New
York but living out here it's a little
different like yo that full I moved so
all my names are like for real
what yeah I know that fool is yeah
neighbor what the hell so I'm sure for
other people like
especially when it's your friends and
you grew up with them especially so they
get so much done too you live in the
same building I think it's the same age
group no they're are they a little
younger same age yeah Underachievers
um and we we lived on Avenue I mean Issa
and his partner AK live in Avenue J so
that's a couple blocks down type [__]
that's sick as [__] so April 21st you
got it's coming out on vinyl it's coming
on the CD good it's got merch with other
designs
related to the project yeah it's all
tied in it's one cohesive I tried to
make uh the sweater the one that says
love without conditions I tried to like
do like some sacred geometry yeah and
the negative scarce in the middle yeah I
don't know what was going to come out as
I just told the artist that's that's the
vibe I was wanting to get and she got it
right and actually looked like some kind
of special geometry [__] it actually
does yeah so what's the best way for the
fans to support this project uh love
without conditions dot Co that's c-o not
c-o-m and you can get the vinyl the CD
I'll probably restart some merch yeah oh
yeah April 21st Spotify Apple music
YouTube music there's gonna be more
videos dropping
yeah we got a single coming out what
currency
okay cool yeah when are you gonna drop
that video sometime from now until the
before the 21st
probably we'll see yeah nine days we'll
see how it goes see how it goes that's
somebody we're trying to get in on here
too it hurts it's dope nice he'll get
here eventually man everybody's gonna
get here and get out of [__] okay here
and like I said we're trying to keep it
like I was getting a little PG but
usually I'm just like but then again
we're trying to talk and this season we
don't smoke half Zips every show anymore
it gets hard to speak
didn't we just we ended right we said to
sign out that's our whole ranting we
just ran for an hour and a half and it's
just not rant City or anymore man it's
not rant City no not to see you've got
to keep us not constantly do it every
episode we just moved to this into this
building in what a month and two months
ago nice space like new new for us so I
like I like this format it's the
reformatting yeah exactly low without
conditions error yeah so uh social media
work everybody find you uh zombie juice
on Twitter and Jews
j-e-w-c-e yeah
j-e-w-i-c-e-i-c-e yeah one day some uh
Japanese guy was like Jewish Jewish and
I was like that's [__] dope
I like it so that's why I named my
Instagram that for at least not because
I'm Jewish necessarily or anything like
that people think I'm Jewish it says two
ice yeah
it's just a deep reference zombie Jew
ice yeah my uncle's Jewish but I'm not
Jewish I don't think I don't think it is
yeah all right so that's on Instagram
and then on Twitch what are you doing on
Twitch like what do you what do you do
on your streams a bunch of nerd [__]
that my fans probably don't care about
the description there's a knee shall
they for everything I'm popping cards
I'm playing Yu-Gi-Oh I'm watching uh
baddies on Zeus Network we're drinking
alcohol we're hanging out we're playing
video games
oh they hate when I play video games I
love video games why do I hate when I
play video games they like it when I'm
talking and watching [__] but I like to
play video games so I can't play video
games on there no more but we're just
doing nerds having fun
awesome yeah love that could be more it
could nerd [__] Best winner back room is
but some nerd [__] what a bunch of toys
but if you like that [__] step in yeah
we got to get that [__] twitch going
I know I know I know I know I know why
not I will why not but on there it's
Larry david420 or just Olivia 420 right
yeah so you kept that old 420 tag yeah I
like that yeah it's fun because like uh
running 2K will give your uh 2K
character like a logo and then my name
will say Larry David 420 but it has like
a microphone logo on there and people
get so pissed off like who the [__] is
Larry
Larry well I am I love this [__] yeah
he's trolling his own family yeah
because someone in my group will say
some [__] and then piss people off and
like oh [__] I love palm trees
I love that song sorry yeah you did beat
the [__] out of me yeah
yeah I can't play games I'm addicted so
I don't even play them anymore it's too
fun yeah that's gambling like we were
talking about oh yeah we never said that
I finally caught the bug yeah I played
roulette and I hit my first number
he was like that virginity Pop I thought
it was just you get your double back and
the guy keeps going I go what what he
goes it's 36-1
and I got stuck and I got stuck and I
stayed for two hours oh no stay for two
hours he was in the I call that the
algorithm if you catch me gambling for
more than two hours I'm in the algorithm
and you better not bother me yeah
something was going right yeah so she's
like yo you better than the numbers I
don't bet on so we'll leave you know
still cool if I lose all my money
because she never loses her money ever
I'm the one that loses it all came like
two bands up down 500 you gotta pull out
every time you win you gotta pull out a
little I do I put the hundreds in here
yeah there we go but I'm looking at her
like you are crushed because she does
plays relent she plays the corners so
she gets like oh well here's
20 to one or okay or 18 or whatever the
split is yeah it's like damn she always
stays in I'm just standing like I don't
want to spend more money man but
gambling's so fun I just didn't know
yeah it is I have a little three 19
because I live in the 19th Floor 16
because the building is 16 55 23
obviously Jordan 24 Kobe 26 because it's
next to three and 35 because it's next
to three
at 13 because it's [__] weird and
those are like my lucky numbers but
lately um I've been running the Drake
strategy Thank You Drake because what's
that strategy I don't know it because
I'm not I don't know the scientific's
behind it but it's like a cross
it's like a cross in the number in the
middle it's like usually 11 for Emerson
[__] yeah 11 17 down all the way little
yeah 26 to the right it's like some
crosses yeah System of a Down fool he's
like yeah what you got to do is get your
lucky number and you bet the numbers
that are around it on the bounce and
like I've been betting for [__] 12
hours nobody told me [__] and then like
you come up here and like yeah you can
split it I started just crushing it yeah
I had no idea mines are 11 5 26 17 33
just because they just I don't know why
they always Bounce Around yeah
anyway yeah gambling [__] gambling
[__] damn it I hate I hate that I love
this so much [__] it it's fun it's fun
so uh we'll see hard hat build Gambler
all right I wear many different hats and
one of them is hard one is hard hats
what was it hard candy Randy no we're
not gonna remember that we're not doing
it
um but for everyone out there that wants
us to go support your album comes out
April 21st yes sir also talking
terps.com yeah please talk in turks.com
dude I don't got I literally walked out
the house put the box down roll the
joint forgot to put the box back up walk
the dog it was [__] up I'm sorry I'm
gonna get you your toy I'm gonna get you
your toy also right here yeah imaginary
special stuff
yeah we'll go to talking terps.com and
then you said uh how do you get the
vinyls and what's the exact Loadout
conditions.com that's c-o not com dot Co
do you get the vinyl vinyls very cool
man because we were just talking about
it last time what three weeks ago to a
guest like nobody does vinyls yeah you
need it people can sign bro like yo sign
my [__] uh my my scroll button we
need it not only because it's cool and
it's a collectible but because we are
not [__] making a lot of money from
these streaming platforms okay so we
need these physical sales it's true all
right
rules the world man like the music
that's how you support it yeah yeah as I
said how can people support you it's not
like yo how can we just go listen I go
support full if you really if you really
like I buy hard I you know me physical
everything because it's like yo when I
see it like yeah I support your [__]
you're awesome I've done it yeah yeah
you do it because you and not even
you've done it before you made music
probably like yo this is if it means
something to you go support it all right
first solo project special man thank you
man number 21st and we'll get the video
sometime before it comes out hell yeah
welcome to my diary man let's go it's
gonna be good appreciate you guys
appreciate you thank you so much
anything else Marty dad this was a
special episode
thanks for being a nerd with this and
letting us talk about stupid [__] and
like dreams because most people I try
not to bring that up but you know thank
you thank you nothing too scary
appreciate you so guys thank you so much
from Marty zombie juice hard hat Bill
thank you for remembering have a dope
ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie